the Biden Administration wants you to
think conservatives are attacking our
democracy but the truth is it's
conservatives who are under assault take
Christmas day where two Republican
lawmakers congresswoman margorie Taylor
green and Congressman Brandon Williams
were the victims of swatting calls we
reached out to the kuga county sheriff's
office to ask what happened in regards
to Congressman Williams and received
this response in part members of our
Sheriff's Office along with the New York
State Police did respond to Congressman
Williams res yesterday at approximately
2: p.m. after receiving a report of an
alleged shooting that had occurred there
we were quickly able to confirm that the
report was false this was clearly a
swatting incident intended to solicit a
law enforcement response to the
congressman's home for an emergency that
did not exist the sheriff is working
with the US capital police to determine
who perpetrated this act which was
clearly designed to frighten and
intimidate the congressman and his
family Congressman Brandon William
Willams joins me now Congressman I'm
sorry that this happened to you on
Christmas I'm sorry for margorie Taylor
green tell me what happened when did you
learn something was a Miss at your
house well I got a call that I didn't
recognize the number and I went to
voicemail and just reflectively I looked
at it and said it's the
sheriff uh their office we're on our way
to your house uh for a shooting incident
and I uh called him back and I said hey
everything's cool here but I stepped
outside
um to greet them outside just think of
it Through The Eyes of a police officer
you see on the screen them coming you
know in heavy into my house um you know
they don't know what they're uh facing
and so I try to just make it easy for
them I gathered my family um in one room
and just told them you know show your
hands be respectful uh which they would
do anyway but uh you really have to
deescalate that because it's it's just
not fair for law enforcement
much less it's very violating in my
family of course it is and Congressman
someone put a sign outside your mailbox
and the sign read this end the war on
Gaza so do you think this is yet another
intimidation tactic because of your
pro-israel
views there's no question you know when
they when they target your house uh
we've had uh neighbors actually that
have had a car stop and say do you know
where the congressman lives around here
can you point out his house this
happened several weeks ago the sign that
you see was several weeks ago as I was
heading to the airport um to go down to
DC and I'm leaving my family at home and
um you know this has happened a couple
of times uh they know where I live and
uh you know these incidents very well
may be
related you know I only have 15 seconds
here but have they found the person who
did this
yet you know it's very easy to hide um
your location when making phone calls
because of Voiceover IP and and all the
different Technologies of how the
telecommunication system works I've
given the police the margin to uh to do
their investigation the capital police
are involved local police are involved
um and uh and not trying not to
interfere but I'm sure I'll get an
update here in a day or two but I've not
heard of any uh uh any leads so far but
I hope that changes wow yeah well stay
safe I know this has happened to
Congress swi green eight times let that
sink in hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else